as you start to grow up you start to
realize how you if you love something
that very much transcends what we think
that definition is you'll never really
understand it until you feel it and just
as much as you too have evolved I'm
pretty sure your level evolved as well
well
I now pronounce you Casey and Tiffany
Chad you may now kiss the brunt it's
still hard to process that I'm getting
married today yeah I'm actually really
nervous about today
I'm actually trying to keep my voice
very monotone very common collected
because I feel like if there was any
excitement that came from happiness it
would naturally turn into nervousness
and I'm just trying to keep my composure
this morning and I'm not even too sure
what I'm nervous about there's
absolutely nothing to be nervous about
yet I'm very nervous I think that you
know through all the phases and titles
that TIFF has had being my crush being a
date a girlfriend a fiance and now
assumed to be a wife I think my favorite
title will always be best friend and I'm
so happy that I can say I'm marrying my
best friend I am nervous and I don't
know why because I know it's gonna be
great we're actually having the dream
wedding I feel so lucky and feels so
blessed and I'm so nervous for the bow
part because I didn't write my vows and
I think Casey didn't write as if I was
either so that means we're just gonna go
up there and say what comes out of our
hearts and while I was taking a shower I
was trying to think of what I want to
say for the vows and immediately I
started crying in the shower as I was
thinking of what I want to say to Casey
oh man I know I'm gonna be a wreck
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
seeing how happy our parents are today
is just incredible I've never seen the
three of our parents that happy ever and
so to see them like that today is just
making this day that much more special
[Applause]
and I can tell that even from the way
that they're looking at each other my
parents they're looking at each other
with happy eyes knowing that hey Casey
turned out alright you guys together be
productive be positive and be supportive
to each other love each other more
everything
just be happy together you know talk to
each other communicate and we always
here for you who support you guys I'm
you guys happiness forever and just grow
old together
thank you
[Music]
so lovely girl
[Music]
to my new mom oh thank you Casey oh my
god I love you so much you've been there
for my daughter whoo cheering - cheerily
needed you you were there when she
didn't have nobody
you make her the woman that she is right
now because of that I love you so much
[Music]
[Music]
people need tequila company Alma you
simplify Ian
[Music]
we should have is that I hope you stay
together for the rest of your life
[Music]
and welcome to our family
I wish YouTube both happy you ever ever
I think besides TIFF and I today really
belongs to Isaac Isaac looks so happy
today I can definitely see how
incredibly happy he is to see us get
married and to know that this is a
permanent thing in his life because
growing up I didn't really have a father
figure in my life to admire and I'm so
grateful that Casey has stepped up and
really committed to being that for Isaac
because he is such an incredibly amazing
father and it's so heartwarming to see
the both of them embrace each other and
love each other as much as they do he
doesn't know it he doesn't realize it I
think he's the one that's taught me more
about life and about how to be a father
than I can ever teach him about life and
how to be a good kid and so this day
really belongs to him
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just to give you guys a heads up if you
guys look around you you know that this
party is very small so just to
understand that is to understand that
everybody here is very special to these
two and there's a reason why you all are
invited
[Music]
it
[Music]
baby
when a Casey first introduced me to
Tiffany I had no idea who she was
she kept on going through these changes
where I just couldn't recognize her the
first time she I met her she had braces
glasses didn't have anything done and I
introduced myself I was like hello nice
to meet you
then a week later I met her again a
brace is gone oh hello nice to meet you
she goes you met me that's like no I
didn't that I meet her again for the
third time no braces makeup glasses off
I was like hello nice to meet you I'm
David just like that this guy hate me
but I just couldn't recognize you seeing
you blossom so much over the years it's
kind of representative of what we see
here today you guys have grown so much
since I first met you and I first met
Casey at a San Diego Film Festival where
he was 30 pounds heavier with long hair
and a lot of grease he was a greasy man
and you've changed them into this
beautiful blossoming man
- so I've seen you guys transform a lot
it's weird because we have like this
concept that we think that we understand
as a kid my mom told me that I didn't
understand what love was when I was a
kid especially like with my very first
girlfriend that first definition of love
is usually physical for men it's the
waist the body the booty and maybe some
of these and we think that's what love
is and it starts to evolve as we grow up
maybe for you I don't know what it is
for women is probably the strong chin
and Casey does have a booty himself it
starts to evolve a little bit there was
three concept loves that my mom told me
that I'll get to understand when I'm
older the first one was the love that
you have as a child to your parents
second is gonna be when you meet your
significant other third is gonna be when
you have a child then you have Isaac and
you should know what that feels like as
well as you start to grow up you start
to realize another three things is how
you view love something that very much
transcends what we think that definition
is you'll never really understand it
until you feel it usually your
significant other will ask you this one
question it goes well usually it's the
girl by the way she goes well what
happens when I'm fat and after we have a
kid in them my faith is saggy and then
my hair is all the stringy are you still
gonna love me then and usually the man
will say of course I will I love you no
matter what what do you love about me I
thought the way that you talk the way
that your voice is the things that you
set your mind there will be a time in
your life there usually a lot of couples
who go through those problems and
they're still together they don't have
the conversations that they used to they
don't look the same that they used to
whether they're older but you still love
them and that's that love that you kind
of gain as you get older and just as
much as you two have evolved I'm pretty
sure your level evolved as well
Tiffany I feel like our relationship
literally walked out of a movie
and it exists in real life I don't
believe in love at first sight but when
I first saw you I thought man I have to
talk to her and I have to be with her
and it wasn't instant either it wasn't
instantly that we were together over
time though I think through my
persistence I think I finally got to you
and we started dating producing we moved
in together and we started a life
together through that I feel like we've
literally blossomed into a perfect
couple
and I don't want to brag but I honestly
think that we have a perfect
relationship and I honestly believe that
we will have a perfect marriage and I
promise to you that I will be a perfect
husband through the dark times and the
low times I promised you that I will
make things brighter and higher for you
and I promise to love our children just
as equally no matter of your love or
blood and I promise to you that I will
be the perfect partner your best friend
the simple things I feel like are the
hardest things to promise simply just
being side by side and being happy I
think those are harder Sims are promised
all those small moments the most
important moments the ones that are
overlooked those will also be perfect I
will never take that for granted and I
won't take you for granted and I love
you I feel like I'm dreaming right now
growing up my entire life I always
constantly would wish I could like turn
back time and change my past and
whatever I went through in life and
meeting you really showed me that I
needed to go through everything I went
through because it led me to you it's so
hard to speak but you know how I feel
inside and you know everything we've
been through and my mind just went blank
but you have helped me grow into the
person I am today and I will forever be
grateful for that and I just promise to
be the best wife I can be your best
friend forever and always be your number
one fan no matter what and I'm just
really looking forward to what the
future holds for us I love you
they freestyle that too by the way that
wasn't written as amazing
as you can see you know you have all
your friends and family here that emerge
isn't just going to be between you two
everybody here that's witnessing this is
also involved so it's a very big
commitment and I want you guys to know
that before you exchange these rings
they're gonna be stuck with these crazy
people for the rest of your life
[Laughter]
KC do you take this woman who thinks
that Tajin is a meal who at times will
work late because of JK news who
probably gives you a lot of headaches
who doesn't understand why you like
movies as much as you do
who stresses you out every time that you
want to critique a film and she's like
sometimes I just want to watch them
stuff do you take her to be your wife
[Music]
Tiffany do you take this man who
constantly critiques your shows like
Game of Thrones which you know you
really like it sometimes he always just
gotta say I don't understand what's
going on this this man who likes chicken
feet for some reason duck ankles pig
nose
noodles I know you don't like noodles do
you take this man to be your husband
would you like to exchange the Rings
AFET Tiffani it's permanent you ready
for that
hell yeah it's gonna be an I do or a
hell yeah hell yeah hell yeah well I now
pronounce you Casey and Tiffany chant
you may now kiss the Brooke
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I mean I hope you guys are enjoying the
view and a lot of photo ops for everyone
and hopefully guys took advantage of it
Instagram dolor but I just want to say
thank you guys for coming out and really
means a lot to us and definitely
upgraded tonight from last night this is
awesome
mrs. Chan yes it's official I am now
mrs. Chan so that's pretty awesome thank
you so much for accepting me into your
family and thank you everyone else for
being here it really truly means the
world to us that you guys could be here
and so it's just been really awesome to
see your reactions to everything like
that's like the number one thing that I
was the most excited for is to see
everyone's reactions to this amazing
venue and all the beautiful work that
has been put into this so we're really
happy you guys cannot be here carry my
brother thank you for being here I know
it's a free ticket for years with the
dad paid for it but uh but Dianna I take
care of them cuz uh cuz you and you guys
are amazing for each other I've I don't
think I've seen my brother as happy as
he is now and so I'm really happy for
you my mom thank you so much for being
here it means the world to me you could
fly out don't cry mom you're gonna make
me cry
I've been crying so much I've been
trying to keep this makeup nice and eyes
like my baby Isaac how do you feel
yay my sweetie pie I love you so much
you've been such a good kid and I'm so
blessed to be your mom and I'm so happy
that you love Casey as much as you do
oh man I'm fighting the tears I love you
Isaac and you know what I'm trying to
say
yeah my baby Baba and Mama thank you so
much for accepting me into your family
both Isaac and I oh my god I think I
could get through this one but you guys
know how much I love you and saying oh
you guys received us with arms wide open
it really means the world to me thank
you so much I stay you wish I could say
more I really truly wish I could say
more but you guys know how I feel you
guys know how grateful I am for
everything everything you guys have done
for Isaac and I we love you and my mom
my dad thank you you've given me such an
amazing childhood and and raised me so
well you guys did amazing job and my mom
if there's one thing I can create a
nutshell for what you've given me is you
taught me how to love and that's been
your essence ever since I was born
thank you so much because you have
raised an amazing man
you really have and then my dad you've
taught me how to seek success I think
for you number one thing you taught me
was ABC always be closing I remember
that I was the day you taught me always
be closing I was like oh that's That's
Life that's life full circle I mean and
I'm trying to make movies now I'm trying
to make movies though perfect I love
that it's poetic so I've actually known
Casey a but as long as he's known Carrie
which is interesting you know we've done
tons of things together we've traveled
together we've you know slumber parties
let her play video games and you know
we've showered together and so the good
thing is I don't do that anymore and I'm
glad to pass off the torch
you know not not my job anymore and you
know Thank You Tiffany but now that
they're all warmed up okay dr. Carrie
literally growing up my role model was
KC everything he does I would do so I
would just follow his step and I've also
showered KC just had to throw that in
there anyways yeah so I'm very happy
that he got together with Tiffany and
Isaac as well it doesn't even feel like
five years like honestly this this
wedding it cements everything officially
but I felt like you two have been a part
of our family for the past five years
honestly and nothing much has changed
except for the title and that's that's
the most beautiful thing is that you
guys have organically become a part of
the family and I'm very happy for our
family everybody here and I'm also very
happy for you too and congratulations
and hope you guys have a happy ending
for the rest of your life if anybody
else wants to come up here and say
something I feel really great I'm glad
now KC is officially my dad and I'm glad
everybody got it came to this moment
where my now dad my now well my forever
mom
my forever mom both of them get to be
together for the whole lives and yeah
I'm very happy for both of these parents
of mine yeah I'm very happy for you too
and I'll always love you too forever and
ever until now until the existence of
human beings
[Applause]
so once they give a speech
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
today I feel that same sort of excited
feeling you get when you sleep over your
best friend's house
you're just having the greatest time of
your lives and you never want it to end
I feel like that today but times a
million because I know that this is
never gonna end I get to have that
special sleepover with my best friend
for the rest of my life and I'm so happy
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]